Speaker 1: I want to look at some Fox News
reaction to what is taking place in the
Russia Ukraine border area, particularly
Donetsk and Luhansk, where Russia has now
invaded slowly. But they've they've invaded.
Fox News immediately went to blame Biden. And
it's kind of I mean, it's sort of funny, but it's
not. I half jokingly tweeted yesterday afternoon
before the invasion, how long until they say
Trump never would have let Putin invade Ukraine?
Or are they already saying it? And it actually
happened very quickly, but was hilariously kind of
spoiled by Fox News's own reporters? Here are some
examples. Hannity spent the vast majority of his
show last night blaming Joe Biden and saying This
is Biden's weakness is what has allowed this to
happen in Russia, Ukraine, etc., etc. This ignores
the fact that Trump was totally under the thumb of
Putin seemed enamored with Putin, as well as many
other authoritarians during his presidency. This
ignores that circumstances have been building for
probably 20 years that relate to what is it, maybe
even more that are now take that relate to what's
taking place on the Russian Ukrainian border. But
despite Hannity spending much of his show blaming
Joe Biden when reporter Jennifer Griffin pops up,
she goes. You know, Sean, actually what's going
on predates this administration. Hannity sort of
upended by his own reporters.
Speaker 2: Sean, how we got to this
point is a long story, and it predates the Biden
administration. It goes back and includes mistakes
made by every US president since the Soviet Union
fell apart, which Putin has said was the worst
geopolitical catastrophe of the 20th century.
Speaker 1: Oh, well, that's not the narrative that
Sean Hannity has been pushing on his show. Even
Peter Doocy, who some consider one of the doofus
reporters out there, Hannity was complaining. Oh,
Joe Biden called the lid. He's not doing anything.
Even Doocy has to tell Hannity. Actually,
even though it's nighttime, Biden is actively
coordinating a response with our allies, and
Speaker 3: the reason that we have not seen him
yet is because they're trying to get everybody
on board, and he's been working the phones,
trying to get a bunch of allies to
sign on to a statement with him.
Speaker 1: Oh, but But Sean Hannity said Biden's
doing nothing and he called the lid and this is
all his fault. This is, of course, so much bigger
than Biden. But the response similarly to when Joe
Biden left Afghanistan, the narrative is Biden
is in the wrong. Biden is the cause of problems.
Biden is the reason we don't have a solution
and the very same people who were saying Biden's
going to get us into wars and Biden's bad and
Trump would have been better because Trump kept
us out of wars. Those very same people are saying,
Well, Biden should have been more aggressive to
prevent this from happening. So they are going
to go with this narrative no matter what. Even
a Republican senator Ron Johnson is doing
the old blame Biden. This was him last night.
Speaker 4: But that fact matter is
there's not much we can do right now.
We should've done is maintain strength.
You do achieve peace through strength. But
that's not just military strength. It's also
economic strength. And as I've seen earlier,
just about every action President
Biden was taken has weakened America.
It's emboldened our enemies. They're
very optimistic. They're very aggressive.
When they sense weakness, they're going to act.
Speaker 1: So wait a second the same people.
This is a reminder, guys, to think, what are
our principles and are we standing by them?
The same people who were saying we should be
more friendly with Russia, we should. We should
be friends with Putin, we should be friends
with Russia. We should be nice. We don't want
war with Russia. Now we're saying Biden's been
too weak. He hasn't shown strength. He hasn't
deterred these people should not even be part of
the conversation. They are just horrible people
and they don't care about anything other than
criticizing Democrats. It's not they. They had
nothing. The conversation, we're going to take a
quick break, and we'll be back with more coverage
of what's happening in Russia and Ukraine.
The David Pakman show is a viewer and listener
supported independent media program a little later
today in the context of upcoming C-PAC, actually,
we're going to talk about what the right gets
right on funding independent media and activism
that the Left lacks. But just remember, it's a
good idea to fund some shows that you like. It
doesn't have to be this one, but I would love
it if you signed up at join Packman dot com.
Lots of great member benefits you can read
about on our website. Join Packman dot com!